[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
surprise à Vichy pour les 15000
spectateurs venus assister à
l'inauguration du nouveau et magnifique
plan d'eau de l'Allier le premier
championnat du monde de cerf-volant
humain un sport qui bien entendu nous
arrive tout droit des plages de Floride
et de Californie
[Musique]
rien de plus facile et d'abord le
décollage
tirer à 75 km/h par un canot automobile
les champions planent à 40 mètres
au-dessus de l'eau
une main
l'autre on descend
[Musique]
et le repart rien de plus facile du
moins pour ses champions
autour maintenant du Hollandais Jürgens
avec Jürgens ce n'est plus tout à fait
du cerf-volant c'est aussi du trapèze
[Musique]
mais que dire alors de Thomas Jones ce
venezuelian a lui-même plus besoin de
ski d'ailleurs son cerf-volant tient
déjà du parachute
[Musique]
mission terminée un sport qui devrait
faire fureur l'an prochain sur la Côte
d'Azur
[Musique]
à Vichy également 37e championnat de
France de boules tous les spécialistes
français du cochonnet étaient fidèles au
rendez-vous
ici la finale du championnat catégorie
honneur
[Musique]
a beaucoup bu du pointeur
partie acharnée également en coupe des
jeunes ces champions de demain ne s'en
laissent déjà pas compter on discute on
palabre on mesure comme des vétérans
[Musique]
finalement l'honneur de Lyon berceau de
la boule était sauf les Lyonnais rafle
deux titres sur 3
[Musique]
on s'est protégé canaliser par les
autorités fédérales la grande marche des
noirs sur Washington a réuni quelques
200 000 manifestants cette marche
entreprise pour réclamer l'égalité des
droits entre blanc et noir aux
États-Unis fera-t-elle de cette journée
une datisterie car on ignore pas que le
président Kennedy a mis au premier plan
de son programme l'abolition de toutes
ségrégation
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si on monstre ou l'ordre a toujours été
sauvegardé à démontré de la façon la
plus spectaculaire l'importance et
l'urgence d'une solution aux problèmes
noirs qui agitent les États-Unis
de l'autre côté de l'Atlantique à
Lisbonne une autre manifestation
réunissait sur la place du Commerce 250
000 personnes où se retrouver les
délégations des provinces d'outre-mer le
Portugal en effet considère non comme
colonie mais comme province et partie du
territoire national les territoires tels
que l'Angola et le Mozambique qu'il
occupent depuis le début du 16e siècle
cette foule était là pour donner son
adhésion à la détermination du président
Salazar de défendre à tout prix
l'intégrité nationale cette
détermination a-t-il dit doit être
interprétée partout comme l'affirmation
manifeste et courageuse de notre volonté
de vie
[Applaudissements]
en application du traité franco-allemand
on a vu à Sarrebourg une compagnie de
grenadiers allemands venir s'insérer à
la place d'une compagnie française dans
un régiment de chasseurs portés quant à
né à Sarrebourg près de Trèves il ne
semble pas que cette intégration est
posée de véritables problèmes
l'apprentissage d'un matériel nouveau ne
crée pas de très grosses difficultés à
des techniciens et les 130 Allemands ont
très rapidement pris leur place sans à
coup dans leur nouvelle unité
ainsi les manoeuvres de char qui
utilisent le nouveau char français AMX
de 30 tonnes veront côte à côte dans les
mêmes groupes allemands et français
parallèlement une compagnie de chars
français a été intégrée pour trois
semaines à une Panzer Division à
Coblence
c'est sans la moindre gêne que les
Français ont pris possession de leur
cantonnement et dans la meilleure humeur
que ce sont déroulés de part et d'autre
les prises de contact ainsi peut-on dire
que ces opérations des changes
militaires sont réussies
[Musique]
que ces jeunes gens séparés hier par 150
ans d'histoire puisse retrouver à la
fois le sens de l'amitié et de la
Coopération c'est un fait plein de
promesses qui contient un germe la
meilleure part peut-être de l'avenir
européen
[Musique]
à Genève ou fut fondé la Croix-Rouge des
délégations internationales se sont
recueillies devant le monument élevé à
la mémoire d'Henri Dunant Henri Dunand
qui avec quatre autres genevois
lançaient voici 100 ans son mémorandum
aux hommes de bonne volonté à travers la
ville un cortège qui groupait plus de
1500 participants représentant une
centaine de pays devait donner tous les
claques qu'elle méritait à cette
commémoration du centenaire de la
Croix-Rouge internationale le
Sainte-Mère d'une idée généreuse qui a
fait son chemin parmi les autres
[Musique]
c'est un jour de deuil pour l'art
universel comme pour la peinture
française Georges Braque est mort dans
sa petite maison parisienne où il vécut
ces derniers mois
vrac restera l'un des moments les plus
considérables de l'art moderne et il est
permis d'affirmer que sans lui et sans
Picasso le mouvement cubiste n'aurait
pas été ce qu'il fut une révolution
réussie l'expérience qu'il entreprite
aux environs de 1910 et qui devait
porter le nom de cubisme allait en effet
bouleversé les conceptions artistiques
dans le monde entier c'est de cette
expérience que devait sortir une
esthétique qui est aujourd'hui la base
même de l'art contemporain sous toutes
ses formes
tout un tiers livré à son art sans
compromission ni réserve la vie de
Georges Braque devait connaître avec
l'admiration universelle les
consécrations les plus officielles et ce
n'est certainement pas la moindre qui
lui ait été donné un jour comme support
à son talent l'un des plafonds du Louvre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous pensez que les chats américains
auraient un rôle à jouer dans la balance
économique française c'est pourtant ce
qui se passe depuis qu'une usine de la
région d'Angers fabrique à leur
intention des souris en tissu bourrés
d'herbe à chat sous l'oeil flegmatique
d'un matou angevin plus d'un million de
ses souris factices sont ici
confectionnés chaque année pour être
exportés aux USA
[Musique]
il est juste de préciser que les chiens
américains font aussi travailler cette
nouvelle industrie française de gadget
pour animaux pour eux on a mis au point
en guise d'os à moelle des bâtonnets à
base de chewing-gum dont il raffole
[Musique]
apparemment les chiens et les chats
d'Amérique s'ennuyaient ils peuvent
désormais meubler agréablement leur
loisirs pour la plus grande prospérité
d'une usine angevine ce qui tendrait à
prouver comme disait le panglos de
Voltaire que tout est pour le mieux dans
le meilleur des mondes possible
[Musique]